foreign  [Music]  in the town of adipour in india's  gujarat state you will find a man who is  arguably charlie chaplin's biggest fans  [Music]  [Music]  practices herbal medicine in his village  and uses charlie chaplin to help treat  his patients  [Music]  laughter is the best medicine  [Music]  dr aswany isn't the only one with a  passion for mr chaplin he started the  charlie circle in 1973 to honor and  remember one of the world's greatest  comedians  charlie chaplin is beloved because of  his every man attitude and comedy that  brought joy to the masses  every year the charlie circle celebrates  charlie chaplin with a parade singing  dancing and of course cake  [Applause]  i  want to keep him alive till i'm alive  and then my grandsons my friends  and all these fellows will keep him  alive because of his marvelous acting  without saying an awards to the public  [Applause]  [Music]  you